I haven't seen you since the Emmys and
you did such an amazing job making the
tribute to Robin Williams
I just had to tell you that I think
while I have you here and it's been nine
months you know you can't orbed it more
I'm guessing
yeah it lets you know that it just is so
terribly odd and a my closest friend and
a huge void but we had such a wonderful
relationship that I look back and makes
me laugh and smile we had phone calls
bill that went on for hours sometimes
they were just absolutely hilarious and
my one big regret was that we had
planned to make an album together of
these phone calls it was a little like a
Derek and Clive Kannada where we could
go blue and dark and and strange so one
day this will be quick I'm watching
Ronald Reagan's funeral on television ah
phone rings I see four one five it's San
Francisco that's him
so hello this is what I hear Oh bill hi
this is Ron Reagan I just wanted to tell
you that everything is okay in him I
said mr. president watching your funeral
and you're in the box oh no that's not
me that's my stuntman he does everything
for me did all the football in that in
that in that Gipper movie that I did and
what way sir let me ask you this what is
what's heaven like people want to know
what's it like well it's a lot hotter
than I thought it was gonna be
so I said hotter so you may not be in
heaven Oh South America is that where I
am is a no sir listen to me if you're
passed on and you think you're in heaven
but it's hotter you may be in the other
place this is home
that would explain why Nixon's balls are
resting on the bridge of my nose but we
don't have him but we have you to
channel them that's great